This is Doug Pitt.
The second most famous Pitt in his family.
Well, hello everyone.
My name is Doug Pitt and welcome to my home.
Come on inside.
Let me take you for a tour.
This is the family living room.
This is where I usually don't get to pick what's on the TV...
...because of the wife, the kids,...
...but a good place to hang out.
This is my man room.
The family doesn't have my appreciation for 70s classic rock, especially loud...
...so headphones come in handy.
I do fancy myself a little bit of the gourmet,...
...making one of my favorites here today, lasagna.
This baby right here, it scans, it prints, it faxes; 1200 dpi black and white.
I'm gonna upgrade to the color but for right now, this baby gets it done.
That's how you do it.
What I like about this car?
Look at it!
It's sporty, it's stylish.
It's me.
While his brother lives the life of a Hollywood A-lister,...
...Doug's life is a little different.
Virgin Mobile believe in a fair go for all,..
...and want to give Doug a taste of his brother's lifestyle...
...starting with his first-ever celebrity endorsement.
Visit FairGoBro.com.au and help show Doug some like.